les monts de l'atlas tout près de medea
une région sous très haute surveillance
un fief islamiste dit on ici depuis
l'enlèvement des sept moines la tension
est encore montée d'un cran
impossible donc dans ces conditions de
se rendre au monastère notre dame de la
classe sans être escortés par la
gendarmerie
c'est le silence des lieux qui
impressionne le plus lorsque l'on
pénètre dans le monastère
pas un bruit pas un mouvement comme syfy
la vie c'était tout à coup arrêté une
croix gravée dans la pierre les moines
trappistes sont installés depuis 1934
un panneau indiquant les horaires des
visites au père luc le médecin du
monastère et notre dame de la classe la
vierge qui protège les lieux ce sont
aujourd'hui presque les seuls signes
d'une présence religieuse à tibéhirine
un moine un seul a décidé de rester le
frère robert il attend le retour de ses
amis il est convaincu qu'ils seront là
bientôt s au moment où vous avez votre
ami le plus cher qui est malade que vous
allez l'abandonner au contraire et
j'allais rester près de lui le jusqu'au
pour vous n'est pas question de rentrer
en france
certainement pas certainement pas au
pied du monastère le village de tibérine
une quinzaine de maisons dans cette
région escarpée loin de tous les moines
sont un réconfort ils aident soutiennent
conseil parfaitement intégré très proche
de la population
depuis cinq jours qu'on attend ici que
leur retour
nous ici on préfère à mourir plutôt que
se soit 500 vous on est perdu j'espère
que dieu nous le ramènera bientôt moi
mes enfants leur explique son manager au
monastère à jean le frère pour des
marchés de niche mais maintenant il dit
et c'est nous qui allons ici au
monastère l'attend paraît de plus en
plus longues et l'inquiétude grandit
chaque jour davantage chacun ici espère
très vite le retour des sept moines car
sans eux la population tibérine n'a plus
ni aide médicale ni le moindre soutien